[Music]
in this world that we live and there's
always a place for black market items
and products and whatnot and there's a
place called the dark web now the dark
web got darker dark could it you know
world is on the dark web you can get
assassinations you get drugs you get you
can get everything
well I'll sorry I can't take you
seriously because you're oh it's going
on with your hair I'm starting a new
look
Oh Samurai Joan samurai pigtail grazie
Joe exotic Joe threatening and douchey
so I did too to be a little cuter how is
it possible that you have not seen Tiger
King I've been busy through what
counties I really want to watch the new
Ozarks I want to watch Tigers
right I mean to like [ __ ] just I don't
know I find a way to [ __ ] make myself
busy dude
I'm busy giving lemons out I didn't mean
to be very distant okay okay thank you
all right so combine the dark web
criminal underbelly of the world and
then you combine coronavirus or the
current pandemic thing happening and
what do you get people selling blood and
saliva Oh or a thousand dollars or more
you mean like selling Corona the post
says that they're selling blood but from
a coronavirus survivor
oh so it's things that people want yeah
so that they could figure out vaccines
or what wow that's dope but then how is
it confirmed though because what if it's
somebody that got syphilis or something
it is not confirmed and in fact people
are saying they're all hoaxes and none
of this blood and saliva is even close
to being corona virus related like this
is just regular blood or regular brain
juice in fact you're my knight and be
the saliva or blood to be sent to the
person buying it and they're just taking
money but that's just the dark web in
general too because let's say you buy
ecstasy pills right yeah there's nothing
to confirm that it's real and you buy it
and in case yeah you guys are well you
test it when you get it right I don't
have a test kit I never use a test you
use my glove I use my tongue you find a
friend what by testament kit I mean
you're a nice kid you don't like that
much and you go hey try this out for
free maybe oh don't - f1 cents get you I
was a test kid cuz it was so I did so
much I just well if this was a pill I
just kept a mic yep mystery works really
has a weird bitterness to it that it's
all pretty much taste in here like a
connoisseur like you feel like if you
lick a tile and all that pie tastes like
that too though
nah tylenol doesn't taste like anything
try it so he's like it Somali but the
sugar coating comes off like if you
scraped it on a sidewalk and you taste
it it's bitter - I watched it up Molly
once ever and then
once what every once I've never yeah it
was good though Bob's like I don't want
to get too into this but I got the pure
form where it looks just like salt and
it did have like a weird taste that like
if I had anything else I ever taste like
that I would know that really it was
like that taste all right now I would
like even like it when I take a sleeping
pill and it touches my tongue before I
can swallow it that [ __ ] is gross and
bitter reminds me just like when I took
tylenol I can't tell the difference
between all the drugs no just don't do
like Tylenol you don't do that [ __ ] no
like harder drugs oh well there's not
good for your liver no yeah I don't do
any drugs either it's not good for your
stomach lining you even like antibiotics
I had to take some and I was like oh
look I don't want to take these man bro
because I worked so hard on gaining
probiotics into my system bacteria mg
you had to eat that's all for nothing
now I gotta redo it it smell like garlic
for another week and I gotta get some
Yakult and [ __ ] yeah you drink that your
call auntie pay antibiotic at the same
time what happened just cancels out with
it you'll just pee that neon pee I don't
know maybe it just kills the Yakult and
you still have the disease just fight
each other
wait so with the people on the dark web
who are they trying to give it to it are
they trying to like trying to sell it to
people that are afraid right now people
that are looking for answers people
looking for they're even selling fake
testing kits for coronavirus they're
selling anything that's Corona related I
don't know what they put in that kit I
don't think there's a popsicle stick or
maybe it's look if it turns brown that's
gonna be a problem
yeah maybe it's the Easter eggs with the
horn in or whatever if you guys ever
even been on the dark web I don't know
how to get there no what is it like is
it like a sectional you have to go on
the internet or a team Chicago WWE dark
web calm I'm just kidding I don't know
and I just thought they know what
websites yeah I don't even know if I you
know there's like all these processes to
Plato's like Windows or whatever right I
don't know if it's like one of the other
weird ones like Linux or some [ __ ] like
it's not even on a normal like [ __ ]
ms-dos age typically for minors and you
don't want to find it normally through
your normal browser because then the
government knows all these dark webs
yeah so then when they see you going
there they're like hey look this is the
guy so you normally use something like
it's called I think an onion browser
yeah and then that one
like it'll ping from a bunch of
different other computers know your
location still on your computer like
with Chrome or some [ __ ] they use a
different use a different browser
differently come on a VPN though I got a
VP VPN but like times like a hundred
makes your locations on one place the
those browsers will fake your location
from like eight steps away I want to see
what I could get on there dark web yeah
I got friends yeah that's the thing like
I know some people like I could get a
rocket launcher right now some people
that have access to the dark web no I
didn't know some people to get something
I want Oh what can you get like a spare
kidney no you guys wanna shoot a rocket
like those [ __ ] massive rockets two
grand what that's it two grand
we did you have to go somewhere though
huh are you making the rocket oh you
know a guy I know a guy oh oh it's not
dark web hypothetically all right
hypothetically not a pathetically Noah
guy hypothetically off the record for
comedy purposes only I saw this I think
was a vice documentary where they went
through the dark web and got connected
with the guy in Russia met with him and
they sold him on nuclear warhead like
one I like small ones Oh what do I do
with this now just the the core the [ __ ]
that could blow up a city like if
someone breaks into my house I'm gonna
throw this out of know you have to do a
lot more and turn into it is it one of
those things if you like putting your
car you're driving in like on bumpy
roads or it could go I think it's just
the learning like the decaying up
chemical right yeah look it's the one
that's created after like if you make a
what they got hydrogen energy like
nuclear energy right the leftover from
that they can use that to make bombs
or time machines over time you're
cutting it back of a DeLorean I hear 88
miles now you can time travel yeah vice
does some crazy [ __ ] though I feel like
some of the bravest people in the whole
entire world are hipster white guys cuz
they don't know the real dangers of the
world [ __ ] you different like
journalists out there with [ __ ]
bullets going by and they're like so I'm
out here in Afghanistan we just see the
jihad happening right behind us
sir why why did you join you know like
there's like there's like blood splat
like yeah that's just the beheading
right next to me delivery it's like
[ __ ] chill as hell yeah yeah it's
because I know the government will bail
them out that's what it is right I'll be
have to be calm if you're gonna have
that kind of job to see that [ __ ] every
day I'll be staggering all the time my
name in a memory purporting to do you
know I would just die a first day on the
job do you see the guy that he was in a
herd of buffalo kay my name they put
that on their main page and Lily oh
thanks for coming and like I ever liked
it but it was so funny because he was
like who's trying to do his job he just
kept looking yeah he was like oh [ __ ]
that
[Laughter]
my favorite [ __ ] is when you see news
reporters during a storm and they're
like yup it's raining and there's a
tornado right there and they just looked
miserable and soaked in the rain and
like what why you out there you can just
point out your window or some [ __ ] why
people do the craziest thing they
storm-chasing oh yeah it got like a tank
I don't just regular Prius whatever and
drive that into like a [ __ ] tornado
yeah and then they have like the little
things on top to like study how fast the
winds are so they're like get closer we
can get better better signal on the
winds are there ever any other
ethnicities I do that [ __ ] I'm sure but
they don't last you do one so yeah no
I'm not
that's true so like I'm curious because
we've said blood and saliva cuz
initially when you set balancing it okay
blood for like ones that have gone over
the corona virus but saliva from the
infected people so you can infect or
from the people that have gone notes so
that so the advertisement is anything
that is gonna help people get over the
core number so like so like like the DNA
and and saliva of people that have
gotten over it testing kits anything
that I freaked out people are like that
will calm me down and they're willing to
pay that I don't know what they would
get it thank God it's the corona spit
and they [ __ ] drink yet care god damn
I do you do a saliva what do you do with
the blood I don't know what you do
nothing and the funny thing is like I do
okay so the people that are panic buying
right yes yeah this is for penny buyers
right on the dark they have access to
the dark webs so you're telling me that
there's the guys that are fighting over
toilet paper or also on the dark web or
these like hackers that are holding the
toilet paper on the no but but they're
paranoid germaphobe hackers
yeah you that's their customer base
exactly you know what's weird is I don't
know it's like I'm reading this article
and I'm not too sure if they're
differentiating between regular internet
and the dark web internet because I'm
not too sure how to dark web works but
they're saying in 2019 only 190 domains
were registered with the words corona or
kovat by January 2020 as balloon to 1400
by February 5,000 now 38,000 Wow income
it's in our everyday like not a day goes
by where I don't say Corona true ever
since this [ __ ] happened mm-hm when it
first happened man everything was Corona
I was like that's Corona crazy
that's Corona not happening that's
Corona beer Corona beer not me like
right when the outbreak happened oh yeah
I think right would have happened before
it was too serious I met a lot of corona
jokes it's also we said Corona before
even it was called Cove it true I still
call it Corona man while the [ __ ]
people calling it co-sign different
things the kovat is when you get sick
the corona is the virus really that
because then there's also us thus our
two Cove something they're all Coronas
oh yeah it's the coronavirus and then
you get Kovan nineteen is a sickness go
copan 19 is a strain of what we're
experiencing now but then the corona
virus is like the farmers all over the
general terms because cough it actually
is stands for corona and then the VI is
virus I forgot the D stand for
coronavirus disease 2019 I don't know
who not mid-nineteen anyway stay up dark
web hopefully you'll not bhai's crazy
stuff I don't know and I hope you die
you guys stay hope you die from the
Ronis what was the first part of that I
hope you guys stay safe from the road
okay
[Music]